oh sh nobody warned me the episode would
start like this hold on pause it I need
to go grab my Edibles and turn on Dark
Side of the Moon I am history of the
Galaxy Parts 1 two and three one being
the best of course what's more
distracting than Ahsoka basically
looking into the camera as she said this
is that she could theoretically be
talking about The Phantom Menace or a
new hope you she could totally be
talking about The Phantom Menace she
could have ended this no thron no war
don't worry Ahsoka even if she had ended
this you'd still have more war when the
first order came along a few decades
later when War's 50% of your title
you're pretty much always guaranteed to
have it a long time ago in a galaxy far
far away cliche we had a deal you
promised me I would see Ezra again no
part of that deal special specifies how
you'd be transported to Ezra got to be
smarter with your bargain to be if
reading Dresden Files has taught me
anything it's that wording in your
Bargains is extremely
important JJ Abrams called he wants his
hyperspace effects back I got confused
for a minute trying to remember whether
it was Lady Morgan or Chris Pine that
was captaining the ship Soo was all like
we hear the complaints about all the
other Star Wars shows having too much
Tatooine and sand so we're not going to
do that but we will make sure everying
planet has a stonehinge enjoy oh goodies
Star Wars version of deadites we've
already seen their version of Star Trek
space whales star Gates and fantasm
balls in this series might as well keep
ripping off as many other properties as
possible your Visions guided me across
the Stars they did not you had a fantasm
ball map and a weird Stargate ship which
we've already covered keep up Els Beth
where is Thon you shall wait he is
coming yeah we've been told that for
fiveing episodes I'm really get tired of
being told to wait why don't youing wait
for one see how you like that
wait I'm sorry what was
that that would just add episodes huh
never mind we'll go with your pace
Ahsoka but I don't like it it
reeks of Jedi the sisters pick up on the
can't even lift a mug with the forc Jedi
adjacent odor of Sabine instead of the
literally trained as a Jedi for years
and even has a master and Apprentice
Dynamic odor of Balin and shin it is
dangerous seriously discout cinnabites
do you back anything up or are you just
accusing people people randomly because
I get enough of that reading
correspondences in the sin's mail room
which also weirdly has a stonehinge this
is a land of dreams and Madness David
Lynch's Ahsoka children's stories come
to life Tim Burton's Ahsoka stories of
this galaxy are considered folktales in
a universe of force Powers witches light
speed travel and aliens of all types I'm
curious what the criteria for being a
folk tail is where's the line of
believability it's the only problem with
having a universe with all these
fantastic things in it well not the only
problem there's also the book of Boba
Fett when I was a bit older than you are
now I watched everything I knew burn I'd
like to go ahead and burn all of my
skips and go ahead and use them here
because I don't care as you get
older look at history you realize it's
all inevitable I fing love everything
about Balin his relationship with Shin
is so respectful and caring his clear
torment from surviving Order 66 is
readily apparent in all of his
Expressions he really is the Charles
Dance of the show so I'm sending the
universe for taking him away so soon
fall of the Jedi rise of the empire it
repeats again and
again and again reason many critics
haven't liked a Star Wars property since
Return of the Jedi makes its way into
this episode why wasn't thon's ship here
and ready when Morgan arrived seems like
they had plenty of notice between when
she popped out of hyperspace and when
she landed on this spire better yet if
these night sisters read the future
shouldn't they have been able to tell
Thon exactly when they would
[Music]
arrive
thraw
F me there are movies that don't look
anywhere near this good everything from
the weathered stormtrooper armor to the
Star Destroyer repaired with golden
lines in a kugi style to this epic
entrance of a villain that has been
hyped in books cartoons and now live
action is just mindblowing take a sin
back while I go change my pants but with
that being said I don't know why Thon
looks like a perfect blend of Robert
Patrick and Elon Musk I understand it is
you I have to thank for my escape from
Exile I mean not really all she did was
refused to destroy the orb Shin had
already retrieved from Morgan and Balin
I wouldn't call that helping as much as
refusing to hinder if you survived I'm
sure he's doing just fine you've GBL the
fate of your Galaxy on that belief and
it is supered up that Sabine did this
and maybe I'll be wrong and she'll have
to pay dearly for the storm she's
brought down on everyone but there
wasn't a way to make all of these things
happen without us having to hate the out
of
Sabine bat dog die well s can die
however she wants thank you very much
man even in Star Wars women are told
what to do with their
bodies having the drop and a clear shot
on your Target in choosing to shoot her
Nintendo switch instead of her head
where the was this Sabine during the
earlier fight with Shin feel like Shen
would have lost both duels if this
Sabine fought them our primary objective
is to escape this galaxy I didn't come
into Ahsoka thinking thon's intentions
will be very similar to kangs and Antman
quantam Mania but here we are it matters
not whether the Ren and Brit are killed
or stranded here if it doesn't matter
then why bother sending anyone after
them at all just keep all your guards
here to play defense in case they attack
and if they don't it's mot my man you
you abandoned me assuming TOA knows how
to speak English also sine asked for a
ride and not a bodyguard so her
irritation to TOA for not fighting with
her seems a little unfair and therefore
sinful you got something going from F
you for being a coward to I trust you
completely and will follow your every
lead is a choice you were thirsty well
no sh Sabine he's been carrying your
armored ass for hours you'd be thirsty
too hey Frank I think I got an idea for
a new creature for the show oh yeah M
what is it well what if you had a
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle but it had
weird long alien eyes and came up like a
mushroom person in Super Mario Bros
that's why they pay you the big bucks M
you steal all your ideas from the best
sources Ezra do do you do you know Ezra
Sabine has been writing for a few hours
and comes cross a single alien who not
only knows who Ezra is but can lead her
to him and if that wasn't unbelievable
enough we'll later learn that these crap
people are migratory so all that to say
this works comes from a breed of boken
Jedi trained in the wild after the
temple fell the heck is a boken Jedi
turns out there are more flavors of Jedi
than there are types of apples but show
doesn't realize that much like apples
I'm only interested in the red and green
ones Star Wars creates adorable alien
baby cliche I knew I could count on you
you were you counting on her to find you
because my understanding is that the
conclusion of rebels made it seem like
you were counting on her to protect
lethal in your absence I just want to be
happy that I found you okay but
betraying ahok and subsequently
guaranteeing the return of the most
dangerous Empire figurehead post Vader
is kind of something you don't just get
to gloss over for a happy moment
especially when you just undercut the
importance of Ezra's sacrifice at the
Battle of lethal the threat of Fate has
spoken to us another comes a Jedi well
your threat of fate is some
because Ahsoka isn't a Jedi anymore just
like Balon isn't a Jedi anymore do you
even know what a Jedi looks like or do
you just accuse everyone you see a being
one and hope you'll eventually be right
I want to know her backgrounds history
home World her master everything you
already know her master you met Anakin
during the Clone Wars bro did you forget
that who's ready for charades Dave's not
here man but per s you have a story for
me and they say Phil kti calmly walked
to the groundskeeper Shack found a
machete chopped those staff members into
100 pieces and they say he took that
same machete chopped his own off I was
hoping for a room with a view I was
hoping you'd be hoping Ken is
invulnerable a 100 men could not fight
Chad this is Elon Musk it's also quite
possible that your friend is dead if you
survived I'm sure is doing just fine are
you the legal guardian of John Connor
and not your V Riders well you didn't
exactly tell any of us where you were
going I was going kind of for a refugee
Motif you know fleeing my homeland kind
of thing